TODD KERPELMAN: So yeah,
welcome, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Todd Kerpelman.
I'm a developer advocate
here on the games team
STEVE MARTIN: I'm Steve
Martin, and
I am not the actor.
And I'm the engineering lead
for the games team.
DAVE SANTORO: I'm
Dave Santoro.
I'm the Android tactical
lead on the games team.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so we are
all here because of in spite
of our formally vaguely worded
title, which we kind of had to
keep up for secrecy reasons.
What we're actually here to
talk to you about today is
Google Play game services.
There we go.
All right.
So let's start by asking
ourselves what are Google Play
game services?
As many of you saw in the
keynote, these are an entire
ecosystem designed to support
your users' gaming experience.
And what does that mean?
Well, that means features like
achievements and leader boards
and saving your game
in the cloud.
It means a real-time multiplayer
framework on
Android devices.
It is a new developer console
experience that is created to
support the whole thing, and
it's cross platform.
So you can earn achievements on
your Nexus 7, and you can
see it on your Chromebook.
I can compare the scores I'm
getting on my Android device
to what my friend might be
getting on his or her iPad.
And in case you're wondering
why we're doing this and
maybe, in particular,
why cross platform.
I suppose the reason is we want
the whole world to play
together, which I know is a
little bit touchy feely, kids
holding hands around
the world.
But at a core level,
it's really true.
All of us on the team
are gamers.
And by that, I don't just
mean that we play games.
We haven't had a lot
of time lately.
It's more that we understand
that games are powerful.
I hope many of you here
are game developers.
You understand this.
Games can push technology
forward.
They drive platform adoption.
They can fulfill human needs
in a way that a spreadsheet
application just can't.
So, sorry, Docs people,
if you're in the room.
We also know most gamers don't
really look like this.
This guy's a little extreme.
There we go.
That's better.
And so we want to make mobile
games more fun and engaging
for everybody.
And we can do this partly by
letting them find good games
that they're interested
in playing.
Let them demonstrate a sense of
mastery and get a sense of
accomplishment.
And let them socialize with
their friends through gaming.
Something that games have
essentially let players do for
thousands and thousands
of years.
So this, in turn, hopefully
helps you as game developers,
because you get a high quality,
engaged audience that
is interested in the games
you're producing.
And you get some of the big
studio features without
needing an entire backend
services team to manage your
database and security, and have
pagers when things go
wrong at 2:00 in the morning.
Hopefully, all of that
makes you happy.
And having you happy
makes us happy.
Also, you've been asking for
this, and we do listen to you.
So we will get into the meat
of these services soon.
But before we do, let's spend
a little time talking about
the ecosystem that we have to
support these services.
We're going to start with Google
Play game services
being social from the start.
We use Google+ sign in for your
identity, which is great
because, particularly on Android
devices, most of your
users are already going
to have an account.
Don't need to create a
username, password.
They're probably going
to be logged in.
And so clicking that sign in
button is then a one or two
click process to sign up
for game services and
get into your game.
If they're like me, they have
their name and their profile
picture set up so that their
friends can find them.
And all my friends can find me
and challenge me to a game.
We don't need to exchange
nicknames or code words or
aliases, or anything
like that.
And social leader boards
are ready to go.
I got 700 people
in my circles.
The minute I click Sign In on
your application, my social
leader boards, the most
interesting kind of leader
boards, are ready to go.
And I can compare scores with
my friends, my family, my
co-workers, and not just some
random dude in a country I may
or may not have heard of.
And by the way, all those
interactive posts, deep
linking, app activities, all of
the other Google+ platform
features, are essentially
available for free when you
implement game services.
So that's nice.
We do know that people are more
willing to sign in with
Google because they trust us,
and they know that we're not
going to inadvertently spam
their friends when they
perform social sign in.
And so to that end, the team has
added some pretty powerful
privacy controls.
The first thing we do is let
the user control which of
their friends they let you, as
game developers, know about.
By default, this is set to
everybody in my circles.
But I might, for instance, have
my secret second family
up in Canada circle that they
don't want anyone, even you,
knowing about.
Oh, so I shouldn't have
mentioned it here.
But I can basically opt to hide
that particular circle
when I sign in to your
application.
We could also ask the
user who can see
their gameplay activity.
Again, by default, this
is set to public.
If I get a high score in a game,
I'm generally pretty
proud of that.
I'm OK if people see it.
But maybe I don't want my boss
to know how much time I spend
playing Rocket Island.
So I can opt to make this kind
of activity visible only to my
friends or, even better, only
to my gamer friends.
It's really up to me.
STEVE MARTIN: So let me start by
explaining why being cross
platform is incredibly
important
to Play game services.
As you're probably aware, there
are a lot of people out
there today that own and play
games on Android devices.
And likewise, there are a lot
of people out there who own
and play games on other
types of devices.
Our goal is to enable everyone
to play with who they want,
not just folks who have a
particular type of device in
their pocket.
This is why being accessible on
any platform is incredibly
important to us.
So let me make that a little
more concrete.
The Play game services are
implemented as a RESTful API.
And what that means is that you
can access them from any
connected device--
phones, tablets, desktop
computers, printers, probably
microwaves.
No platforms excluded.
We're offering generated
libraries in lots of different
languages in addition to custom
library specifically
geared towards mobile games.
So let's talk more about
those custom libraries.
Our custom libraries
are specifically
built for iOS and Android.
We recognize these
as the common use
cases at the moment.
The libraries simplify
development by taking care of
a lot of details.
So for example, some of the
nasty edge cases in OAuth 2.0.
And I'm sure there's some people
out there who know what
I'm talking about.
The libraries also offer a
lot of extra good stuff.
So for example, auto-retry
if your gamer happens
to go into a tunnel.
Air handling and trapping.
A whole set of UX widgets
that you can drop
right into your game.
Also caching to reduce network
use and prevent your game from
draining the battery.
All the code samples in this
presentation use these
libraries, and you
should as well.
So as you probably expect,
library integration differs
between iOS and Android.
On iOS, you download a
framework, and then you add it
to your project.
Every time you update that
framework, you need to publish
a new app update which
your users need to
go and get and install.
This is a standard,
well-understood of the life
cycle flow for iOS
application.
On Android, we have a thin
client that talks
to on-device service.
The client library is in the
Android SDK, which you see
here in the lower right.
The core functionality for
Play game services is in
Google Play services.
And this service is being
updated on all your gamers'
phones even as we speak
here today.
So what does this mean?
Well, it means that Play game
services updates and bug
fixes, we automatically
distribute it to all your
gamers without them having
to do anything.
We really like this design
because we think it's going to
be a great benefit to both
developers and your gamers.
So there are many other benefits
to integrating Play
game services on Android.
And one of them is the
introduction of additional
anti-piracy protection for games
that are distributed
through the Play store.
I love that.
All right, so the games team
shares your concerns about the
impact of piracy on games.
I mean not every Android game
has to be free to play.
We'd much rather you guys have
a choice in the matter.
So how does this work?
Well, our backend server can
detect when a player hasn't
downloaded the game from
the Play store.
And we can return an error to
the game if you so choose, and
then you can decide what
your games does next.
This means that you can choose
whether or not to let pirated
games use Play game services.
So for example, multiplayer.
You can choose a pirated
game to not let it
use multiplayer features.
You can turn this on or off
via our developer tools.
And we'll be getting into that
more in just a second.
Play games services also
brings significant
enhancements to discovery.
And one of these is the
introduction of badging in a
Play store.
This highlights games that use
Play game services that a
gamer might find interesting.
So for example, this game uses
leader boards, achievements,
and multiplayer.
This will make it easier for
gamers to find games that
interest them.
OK, so enough intro.
Let's dive into an example.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So this is our studio's hot
new game, Angry Fruit.
This is a game where you help
fruit resolve their anger
issues through active
listening and
deep breathing exercises.
And we did check, a tomato
is a fruit so it counts.
We think this is going
to be the hot
new game of the summer.
However, early play tests have
shown that the game has two
significant issues.
First, nobody's really trying
out Blended Fruit Mode.
We don't know why.
Maybe it's the name.
Maybe they can't find
it in the menu.
Second, Endless Mode isn't
retaining particularly well.
People do try it, but then they
kind of give up after one
or two plays.
So let's think about how we
would solve these problems by
adding some Google Play
game services love.
And the first thing we need to
do is visit the new Google
Play Developer Console.
You might recognize this console
if you have uploaded
or published any Android
games in the past.
And if you're here at Google I/O
in the Android track, I'm
guessing maybe you have.
What might be new, however, is
this little controller icon
here on the left.
There it is.
So following this will take you
to the new game services
section of the console.
And this is where we could add
a new entry for our Angry
Fruit game.
We would add our game's
name and description.
We would add a few graphics,
and these would basically
determine how this game would
appear throughout our service.
At this point, we could link
our game to an Android
application.
You can link the same game entry
to both an Android and
an iOS application if you wanted
them to share leader
boards and achievements.
You could also keep them
completely separate.
If it turns out the browser
version of Angry Fruit is
significantly different than
the mobile version, and we
don't really want them to share
leader boards, we can
basically have two entries
and just keep them
separate that way.
It's basically up to you
as developers what
you'd like to do.
There's a whole lot more, by the
way, that this Developer
Console does, including creating
OAuth 2 client IDs
for you, publishing just to
trusted testers, adding
localization support, adding
seasonal updates,
and much, much more.
If you are interested, drop by
the Practical Play Games
Pointers talk that is
immediately following this
one, but I think over
in room five.
So you're going to have walk.
All right, so that was
a lot of setup talk.
Let's talk about adding some
code starting with the Android
version, which is something
I know nothing about.
So it's a really good
thing Dave is here.
DAVE SANTORO: Thanks, Todd.
So to integrate with our
services on Android, the main
class you'll be working with
is called GamesClient.
This basically provides
the entry point
to Google Play services.
It handles getting the user
connected and signed in and in
a good state to interact
with your game.
And it takes care of, basically,
providing all the
access to the APIs that you
have through our service.
So generally when you're
creating a GamesClient, you'll
need to hook this into
your activity or
fragments life cycle.
We basically want to make sure
that you don't keep the
service connection around
longer than necessary.
So the main pattern that we
recommend is that you'll
create the GamesClient in
your onCreate method.
And as you can see, it takes
three parameters to
create one of these.
You'll need to pass
in a context.
You'll need to pass in a
connection call back listener
and a connection failed
listener.
And if you're using an activity
or fragment, all
these can just be
the same thing.
Next, we'll handle connecting
and disconnecting the client.
For this, we recommend that
you just hook these into
onStart and onStop methods.
We just want to make sure
they stay symmetrical.
So anything you create,
you also clean up.
Next, we'll handle connection
failure case.
So there are a couple different
things that could
cause connection failure.
The most common case is that
the user isn't signed in.
If that's the case, the
connection results that you
get back from this call will
give you a resolution intent.
And all you need to do is launch
that intent, and this
will take the user through
the sign in flow.
Get them signed up for
G+, if necessary.
Get them into a good state
to use the service.
Another possibility is that
something more broadly is
wrong with the device.
So for example, maybe they don't
have the latest version
of Google Play services.
If that's the case, you can use
this Google Play services
util method to get
an error dialog.
Display that to the user and
this will walk them through
what they need to do to
get into a good state.
This may seem a little bit heavy
weight, but really all
the code up here is just
kind of boilerplate.
And you won't need to do
much different than
what this is showing.
Finally, we'll handle
connection success.
If you get the onConnected
callback, it means everything
is ready to go.
You can call any of the other
APIs that we support through
GamesClient.
You don't necessarily need
to do anything here.
Some of our Trusted Tester games
have done things like
get the user's name and show it
in-game to make it really
clear who the user
is playing as.
But you can do whatever
else you need to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, so
before I start talking about
the iOS implementation,
just show of hands.
Who here does iOS development
on a regular basis?
All right. there's
a few of you.
Everyone else, get them!
Everyone check your email or
just look at all the brackets,
it's up to you.
So the first thing you want to
do in iOS is set up your
GPPSignIn object.
This is a process that you've
done already if you've
implemented Google+ sign-in in
any of your applications.
Basically, you're going to
access this shared singleton
instance, and then you're
going to set a number of
properties on it.
You'll set your Auth client
ID, your default
language, and so on.
The one thing that should
probably look different to you
is this scope.
I should look over
this shoulder.
This is the game scope,
and this is
obviously for game services.
You would do this instead
of the plus.login scope.
Games is kind of a superset,
so you don't need this in
addition to plus.login.
Once that happens, you would
call authenticate.
You could either do this through
your own game engine
rendered button.
Or if you're using the official
Google+ sign-in
button, it makes this
call for you.
At that point, the user
will be taken
to the sign-in process.
And assuming they click accept,
they'll come back to
your application, and that
moment will be captured here
in the finished
finishedWithAuth:error handler.
At this point, you would check
if there any errors.
The most common one is the
user clicked Cancel.
But if they didn't,
we'll assume that
everything went well.
And at that point, you can
take your GPPSignIn
sharedInstance--
there we go--
and you can pass it in
to your GPGManager.
GPGManager here is for Google
Play games manager.
And this is kind of the master
class that handles all of the
main game services
for your app.
You would also add a reauthorize
handler, and this
basically specifies what to do
if Auth fails for some reason.
9 times out of 10, the
right thing to do
is try Authing again.
At this point, the user should
be signed in to game services.
They'll see a little "welcome
back, Todd" message at the top
of their app.
Results might be different
if your name isn't Todd.
And at that point, they're ready
to go and implement some
game services.
So let's add in achievements.
What do you think, Steve?
STEVE MARTIN: I think there's
a great idea.
So we think achievements are
super important in games for a
couple of different reasons.
So first of all, they give
players a feeling of
accomplishment.
I mean, I did something.
The game recognizes that.
Pops a nice toast.
I get an achievement.
I feel good.
And secondly, they give
your hardcore players
something to aim for.
So I got that rare headshot
achievement.
None of my buddies have it.
Serious bragging rights.
Thirdly, they encourage
exploration and repeat play.
So I can personally
attest to that.
I've stayed up way too late
multiple times, possibly even
this week, in trying to get
all the achievements in a
particular game.
And finally, they can drive
player behavior.
So your solo player might be
enticed to give multiplayer a
shot if there's an achievement
for it.
So achievements look
like this in the
client UI that we provide.
This is the iOS version.
You can actually make your own
client UI, and we'll be
talking more about how
to do that later.
There are three states.
Unlock, hidden, and locked.
Unlocked and locked work pretty
much exactly as you
would expect.
And hidden lets your game choose
when to reveal the
existence of this achievement
to the player.
We have two flavors
of achievements.
What I like to call traditional,
which has just
the three states that I talked
about previously, and also
incremental, which records
additional
progress towards an unlock.
All the states for these
achievements
is kept on the server.
There's nothing for you to do
locally except ask the server.
OK, so if you remember our Angry
Fruit example, we had a
problem with it.
And that was nobody was trying
Blended Fruit Mode.
So why don't we try and entice
users to explore this mode by
adding an achievement?
So let's do it.
We're going to add an
achievement for completing 10
levels of Blended Fruit Mode.
We're going to call that
achievement Smoothie Operator.
So here's how we set it up in
the Play Developer Console.
First, the basics.
You need to give us a name
and a description.
These are localizable, and we'll
be discussing that in a
talk later today.
These will also appear in the
client UI that I showed a few
slides back.
From there, we'll
need an icon.
We need to know the type
of the achievement.
In this case, it's
incremental.
Remember, 10 levels of
Blended Fruit Mode.
We need to know the
initial state.
So in this case, it's revealed
so the user knows whether or
not the achievement
actually exists.
We need to know a measure of
this achievement's importance.
And we express that
via points.
We don't do anything with the
points right now, but we have
big plans for it later.
And finally, where to show this
achievement in a list of
achievements.
And in this case, it
shows up first.
So once it's saved--
bam.
You get back an ID.
You use this in the code to
refer this achievement.
And while we're at , let's
add a couple other ones.
We'll add a Fruit Whisperer
achievement for winning the
game and then a Top Banana
achievement, which is a hidden
achievement, for winning
the bonus level.
So let's hook these up.
DAVE SANTORO: All
right, great.
So we have some achievements.
On Android, you hook
them up like this.
First thing we'll do is create
some local string constants.
We don't want to be referring
to those gnarly strings from
the Play Console everywhere.
So we'll create some local
constants here for Smoothie
Operator and for Fruit Whisperer
and Top Banana, and
all the other achievements
that we've defined.
Now we'll do the handler for
when a user wins the game.
So in this handler, the first
thing we want to do is unlock
the Fruit Whisperer achievement,
because we want
to unlock that anytime the
user wins the game.
You'll notice that in this
case, we're calling this
without any listener
attached to it.
This is what we call
the fire-and-forget
form of these APIs.
Regardless of whether you're
listening or not, this will
basically go to the service.
The service will keep retrying
to the server if
the device is offline.
You don't need to worry about
it anymore as a developer.
For our incremental achievement,
we do care about
the result.
So in this case, we're going to
call the Smoothie Operator
achievement in a mode that
contains a listener.
So in this case, we call
incrementAchievementimmediate,
which means we want this to
go out to the network
immediately.
And we want to hear what
the result was.
We pass in the listener, and we
pass in the number of steps
to increment it by.
So the listeners all look
something like this.
You'll always get back a status
code, and this lets you
know basically what happened
when you did this operation.
Maybe the device was offline,
maybe it was successful.
You could look at the Java doc
for the listeners to see what
status codes you might expect,
and what all those signify.
In this case, what we'll do is
check to see was this the
Smoothie Operator achievement?
And was it finally unlocked?
And if that's the case, we'll do
a couple different things.
First, in game, we'll enable the
bonus stage for the user,
because we want unlock some
additional content for them in
response to this achievement.
And then we'll reveal the
achievement for Top Banana,
which they'll earn by completing
the bonus level.
So how do we display
achievements?
Whether you pass in a listener
or not, a toast just popped up
automatically.
It looks something like this.
If you don't want your pop-up
to display at the top of the
screen, you can very easily
control that.
There are some methods on
GamesClient Builder that let
you set the particular view that
you want to anchor all of
our pop-ups to, as well as which
part of the screen you
want to display it in.
So if we want to show in the
corner or on the bottom
instead of the top, you can do
that using these methods.
It's also really easy to
bring up our in-game
achievements widget.
This is what it looks
like on Android.
All you have to do is ask
the GamesClient for the
achievement's intent
and launch that.
And you're good to go.
So we recognize that not
everybody wants to use the
stock achievement widgets.
So we want to have the ability
for you to build your own.
To that end, you can ask
the GamesClient to load
achievements.
And in the call back for that,
you'll get back an achievement
buffer that contains all the
achievements that you've
defined along with the user's
progression on each.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
let's talk about
achievements on iOS.
All achievements, basically, you
interact with by creating
a GPGAchievement object.
And you do that by calling
this helper class method
achievement with ID.
And here we're passing
in the NSString.
That's the hardcoded string
we got back from
the Developer Console.
Once we have this, we
can interact with it
in a number of ways.
There we go.
We can unlock our achievements
by calling our
unlockAchievemen
etWithCompletionHandler method
because we're in iOS, and we
like really long method names.
My handler here is set to nil.
But really I should be setting
my call back here so that I
can check for any errors.
I can also find out whether
this was a newly unlocked
achievement by the user.
Again, you don't need to keep
track of this on the client.
The server will keep
track for you.
We can increment our Smoothie
Operator achievement by
calling
incrementAchievementNumSteps--
NumSteps is the amount of
progress you're making--
and then another
completionHandler, where we
tell you was this newly unlocked
and how much total
progress has the user made
up until this point.
At this point, we decide, hey,
this is a newly unlocked
achievement.
We'll unlock our bonus level.
And we can also reveal the
previously hidden Top Banana
achievement, which we would do
by calling revealAchievemen
tWithCompletionHandler.
Hopefully, all that is pretty
straightforward.
Notifications are brought up
automatically by the library.
However, we know that maybe
on iOS there are other
achievement systems you
might be implementing.
So we give you the option
to hide these
notifications if you want.
So bye.
It's very simple to bring up
the achievement widget.
It's about three
lines of code.
And this is basically all UI
generated by our library that
displays all of the user's
progress to them in terms of
the amount of achievements
they've earned and unlocked.
and we also have raw
data APIs if you
want to do this yourself.
And so with our achievements
done, let's add a leaderboard.
STEVE MARTIN: Yes.
Leaderboards.
So we feel that this is a super
important engagement
tool for developers.
And the primary reason why is
that it's probably not a
stretch to say that most
players like comparing
themselves against
other gamers.
And leaderboards can
help with this.
They bring a simple, lightweight
competitive
element to your game.
They'll make your games
much more engaging.
So we've built two types
of leaderboards
in Play game services.
The first of these is public
leaderboards, and this is your
score compared to the scores of
everyone else in the world
who have also chosen to show
their scores publicly.
And if you can't make it to the
top all-time across the
entire world, well that's OK.
We got your back.
You can try any other
timespans we offer--
weekly and daily.
So comparing yourself
to a list of total
strangers can be fun.
I mean, we all remember the
arcade days when there were
lists of unintelligible
initials.
No idea who these people were.
You just know that you put in
a quarter, and you beat XYZ.
And that's pretty cool.
Well, imagine instead of that
experience, you had a list of
people with profiles
and names.
And these were all people
that you actually knew.
And furthermore, these are all
people that you know that
actually have lower scores
than you now.
So we think that's a much more
engaging experience.
So we are also adding
social leaderboards.
And what this will do is let you
compare your score to the
scores of your friends,
your family,
anyone in your G+ Circles.
You can add to your Circles on
the website or via the apps,
and those scores will
show up here.
And of course, you control
your data.
As Todd mentioned earlier, if
you don't want your scores to
show up, well, we give
you tools for that.
And of course, if you can't beat
your friend's all-time,
well, again, we have the weekly
and daily timespans.
So we're extremely excited about
social leaderboards.
With the amount of truly
ridiculous competition in the
office is any indication
whatsoever, pretty sure these
are going to drive engagement.
All right, so back
to Angry Fruit.
We solved our Blended Fruit Mode
issue with achievements.
So you remember that.
But if you remember, we also
had a second problem.
And that problem was our Endless
Mode isn't retaining
users well.
I mean, they come in.
They play.
They get a score.
But they never come back.
So let's use social leaderboards
to add a little
special sauce.
When you add a little social
competition, that'll keep
people re-engaging and competing
with their friends.
All right, so let's do this.
We'll make a leaderboard
for our Endless Mode.
Like all leaderboards,
it'll have both
public and social views.
To start, we'll need a name.
We'll need you to optionally
tell us how to interpret the
scores that you submit.
A score formatting.
We'll need an icon.
We'll need to know the ordering
for your score, so
basketball or golf order.
We'll need optional limits, and
what these limits will do
will cause a server to reject
any score outside the limits
that you specify.
This is also optional.
And then we need to know where
to show this leaderboard in
our list of leaderboards.
And in this case, we're going
to have it show up first.
So once you save it,
you get an ID back.
Very similar to the achievements
process.
This is the ID that you
use in your code.
But before we get to that, let
me talk a little bit about how
scores are rendered.
So you submit scores
as 64-bit integers.
However, the API returns both
the values that you submit and
rendered strings.
And these strings are there so
that you can make your own
leaderboard UI with your
own list of scores.
So here's an example
of how this works.
As you can see here
on the left, we
have the English example.
The time interprets your
values as milliseconds,
whereas the currency interprets
your values as
micro dollars-- one one
millionth of a dollar.
Apparently, that's a standard.
On the right side, we actually
do localize these scores.
So a German caller might find
these a little more easy to
understand.
All right, so now let's add our
leaderboard to Angry Fruit.
DAVE SANTORO: So integrating
with leaderboards works very
much the same way as integrating
achievements.
The first thing we'll probably
want to do is add some
constants to refer to those
leaderboard IDs that we got
from the dev console.
With the leaderboard ID, you can
then submit a score either
immediately or using the
fire-and-forget mode.
And you'll just pass in the raw
score that you want to add
for the user.
If you pass in a listener,
you'll get a bunch of
information back about what
actually happened here.
So this will include information
about what the
user's top score is for all the
timespans that we support,
as well as whether the score
that you just submitted is the
new top score for the user
for that time period.
So you can use this to show
something cool for the user if
you want to.
Displaying leaderboards.
Again, similar to
achievements.
We have one intent that lets you
show the list of all the
leaderboards for the game.
So this is what that
looks like for
Asphalt 7 by Gameloft.
And you can also show a specific
leaderboard by
calling getLeaderboardIntent
for the leaderboard ID that
you care about.
And, once again, if you don't
like the leaderboard UI that
we've created, we can provide
raw data APIs so you can load
in the data for scores of
everyone and display the UI
however you want to.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool.
Thank you.
So on iOS, we interact with
leaderboard similar to how we
interact with achievements.
Instead of creating a
GPGAchievement object, we
create a GPGScore object.
And we associate it with the
leaderboard by calling this
scoreWithLeaderboardId
helper method.
You assign it a value.
And then, basically, to submit
the score, you call
submitScoreWithC
ompletionHandler.
You'll get back, in
that completion
handler, a GPGScore report.
And you can analyze this report
to find out whether
this is a new daily, weekly,
or all-time high
score for this user.
And if it isn't, what's the
previous high score that they
need to beat.
We let you display a single
leaderboard by, again, about
three lines of code.
And we also let you display
a list of all available
leaderboards if your game
supports more than one.
We also have raw data
APIs available.
Although, leaderboards tend to
be a little more complicated
than achievement, so sometimes
people just go with the
built-in widgets.
So let's assume things are going
well with Angry Fruit.
People are now playing Endless
Mode because they want to beat
their friends.
However, it turns out there's
one more problem that we are
now seeing.
A long time, loyal players
suddenly stopped playing and
for no apparent reason.
And except maybe for the fact
that their device seems to
have changed.
And this brings us to my
favorite feature which is
Cloud Save.
It might not be as sexy as
leaderboards, but it's really
my favorite feature
and here is why.
Think about how many households
out there have a
phone and a tablet right now.
In fact, show of hands.
How many of you have more than
one device at home used on a
regular basis?
All right, that's
like all of you.
So based on this completely
unbiased Google I/O attendees
sample, 100% of the world has
more than one device.
More interestingly, how many
of you have an iOS and an
Android device that use
on a regular basis?
All right, that's a pretty
significant number of you, and
I think that number is
going to be growing.
So now think about it, how many
times have you unlocked
the first 30 or 40 levels of
a game, gone to play it on
another device only to find that
you need to start over
again from level one.
And said to yourself, wow,
this is a fantastic user
experience.
I can't believe I get to play
the entire game over again.
All right, I saw one hand.
I think he's just raising
his hand for fun.
So maybe more importantly, how
many of you have decided not
to continue playing a game as
soon as you got another
device, because you didn't want
to have to start over?
I know I haven't.
All right, so all those hands
in the air, those are people
that are no longer playing
your game.
They're not seeing ads.
They're not telling their
friends about your game.
They are not contributing to
leaderboards, and they are not
buying in-game items.
Which is a shame and it's
money out the window.
And it's a problem that
we want to fix.
And so for that, we have
introduced a very simple cross
platform, save info for this
user to the cloud kind of
functionality.
In case you are wondering how
this fits into our other
services because we are Google,
we like to do a lot of
things in the cloud--
cloud saving really is just
designed to do one thing and
do it well and do it simply.
We have other services like
Google Drive, which lets
multiple people edit
the same file.
Lets you view revision
history.
Lets you see very large files
to a folder that can be
re-shared later.
And we've got App Engine which
allows for a very complex
server side functionality and
database-like storage and cron
jobs, and that sort of thing.
These are much more
powerful systems.
But with great power comes great
responsibility, and a
little more setup time.
So the analogy I like to use is
Cloud Save is a little like
a cheese grater.
Google Drive and App Engine is
a little more like a chainsaw
There are a lot of things you
can do with a chainsaw.
You can cut down trees, juggle,
carve ice sculptures,
fight zombies.
But if all you want to do is
grate some cheese for taco
night, the chainsaw's probably
going to be more power than
you need, and you're going to
make a mess of your kitchen.
So similarly, if all you want to
do is keep the user's data
from one device to the next as
they play your game, start
with something simple
like Cloud Save.
And then as you find your server
needs to grow, and you
need more sophisticated
functionality, then consider
switching to something like
the App Engine or Compute
Engine, or some of our
other cloud services.
We're going to give you a really
whirlwind overview of
how Cloud Save works.
You have four save game slots
in which you could say data,
which in a fit of creativity
we've labeled zero through
three because we're engineers.
They hold 128K of data each,
and these could be used to
manage multiple save
slots per user.
You can also use them
to intelligently
partition your Save data.
For instance, if I were making
a role playing game, I could
save the user's avatar, their
avatar look in one slot, their
inventory in another,
and their quest
progress in a third.
And that way, if my user decides
to change the look of
their avatar, I only
have to upload that
chunk of the Save file.
I don't have to upload
the entire thing.
So let's see what that process
looks like behind the scenes.
Up in the cloud, you've got your
game's data along with a
unique version string.
You can think of this like a
timestamp or [? NE ?] tag.
When I want to retrieve this
data, I make a GET call.
And in the GET call I specify
the state game slot I want.
And the service returns that
data along with the unique
version string.
And I store that on my device.
So that's fairly
straightforward.
Now let's say I were to update
this data, and I
want to save it now.
I would send across this new
data to the cloud along with
the old version string.
The service would make
sure that those two
version strings match.
If it does, it says, OK,
this looks legit.
It will update its version of
the data, update its version
string, and then send me down a
200 code along with the new
version string.
So let's look at the
case of a conflict.
Let's say I update the data on
my phone, and then I'm also
ambidextrous and playing on my
tablet with my other hand.
And I save data there, too.
So up in the cloud, there's
this new data and this new
version string.
This time, when I send across
my data from my phone, the
service will check and see if
the two version strings match.
If it doesn't, that's a sign
that somebody else has gone
ahead and updated the data while
my phone wasn't looking.
And the service gets
unhappy about that.
It doesn't quite know what to
do, and so it sends me down a
409 conflict code.
At this point, the iOS and
Android libraries will go out,
and it will retrieve both
sets of data and
present those to me--
or to you, as the
game developer.
And you'll get sort of the local
data, the data that you
are attempting to save, along
with the data that has been
updated in the cloud while
you weren't looking.
And it's up to you to decide how
you want to resolve these.
Maybe you sort of
perform a union.
Maybe you pick one
over the other.
Maybe you give the user
a dialog box.
Maybe you find some other
intelligent way to merge based
on your game's logic.
It's basically up to you, but
that data would then be used,
again, to update to the cloud.
I know we sort of went through
this kind of fast.
We're going to be covering this
in more detail in the
Advanced Game Topics talk
that I believe is
happening at 5:00 or so.
So stick around for that.
So let's talk about
code and what this
looks like on Android.
DAVE SANTORO: So to interact
with Cloud Save, you'll be
using AppStateClient instead
of GamesClient.
The setup for AppStateClient
looks almost exactly like
GamesClient.
You'll still pass in three
parameters to construct one.
You'll need a context
and a success
listener and failure listener.
And then we also recommend that
you hook this into your
activity or fragment's lifecycle
the same way.
Create and uncreate.
Connecting and disconnecting
it.
And on start and on
stop, and so on.
If you are going to use both
the GamesClient and the
AppStateClient, I do recommend
that you attend the Advanced
Game Topic session.
They have a lot of really good
tips on how to gracefully
interact with multiple
clients at once.
So once you have a connect to
AppStateClient, you can call
the sort of methods
you'd expect.
So we have a loadState method
that lets you load the state
for a particular key.
There's a listStates method the
lets you see which keys
you've stored data for so far.
And you can update.
And as with the other APIs,
you can either update this
immediately and attach
to listeners
so can get the response.
Or you can update it in the
fire-and-forget form and trust
the service to get it to
the server for you.
So conflict handling on Android
happens at load time.
If you get an
OnStateloadedListener, there
are two possible call backs
that could be hit.
First one is onStateLoaded.
This means everything
was fine.
The data got up to the server
correctly, and you have
everything up-to-date on the
device, so there's nothing
special you need to do here.
If you get an onStateConflict
callback, you get into this
case that Todd just mentioned
where the data on the server
differs from what you
have on the client.
And in this case, you get back
the server version, as well as
the local and server-based
data.
And then you can compare those
two and do whatever sort of
merge makes sense for you.
And then to resolve that, you
just call resolveState.
You pass up the version string
that you got from the conflict
callback, and you pass
up the new data
that you want to store.
TODD KERPELMAN: Cool.
So on iOS, you access Cloud Save
data by referencing your
GPGAppStateModel.
AppState's kind of our internal
name for Cloud Save.
Once you get this model, you can
load data from the cloud
by calling loadForKey.
Key is an NS number between
zero and three, with a
completion handler.
And the two most common status
messages you get back in the
completion handler are either
not found, which generally
happens if this is a user that
has never saved data before.
Usually it's a brand new player,
and you load up some
default data.
And success, which means, yay,
everything went fine.
This method does have
a conflictHandler.
I like to think of this more
as a heads up handler.
It is basically the service
telling you, hey, looks like
some other device, not
this one, has been
saving data to the cloud.
And you might want to just
take a look at it.
Sanity check it, and make
sure everything is cool.
Give the user a dialog box
saying, hey, we got to reload
the interface.
Something like that.
To save data to the cloud, you
call updateForKey with a
completionHandler, and also
with a conflictHandler.
And this conflictHandler
contains the two sets of data
that you will need to
work to resolve.
This is sort of the local state
that you're trying to
save and the server state, which
is apparently the state
that's been updated in
the cloud while your
client wasn't looking.
Again, you can resolve this
in a way that makes
sense for your game.
Return it, and then the library
will try once again to
save this to the cloud.
And hopefully then, it'll hit
your completionHandler.
STEVE MARTIN: All right.
Cool.
So let's wrap up quickly
with one more feature.
Possibly our coolest
feature overall.
Real-time multiplayer
for Android.
So this works across all Android
devices running Google
Play services, which is
currently for [? AO ?]
and newer.
There are a number of games both
out today and coming soon
that have integrated with it.
Example here is Riptide 2.
We actually have that running
over in the multiplayer kiosk
right outside this room.
Please go play it.
It's actually a really
great game.
We actually really enjoy
that quite a bit.
The API supports two
to four players.
Our client UI, shown here,
actually makes it easy to
invite friends directly
from your G+ Circles.
You can use our auto-matcher to
fill in any empty slots in
a match, or create a quick
match with nothing but
auto-matcher.
Once a match is formed, the
Android service in your device
creates a peer-to-peer network
between the devices.
And the networks supports both
reliable and unreliable
messaging, which is available
through both message type and
socket type APIs.
OK, so briefly, I want to talk
about how multiplayer invites
can actually enhance discovery
for your game.
It's a great way for gamers
to find great games.
So here's an example scenario.
So let's say a player in my
Circles has a great new game,
and he wants to invite
me to play with him.
So he creates a match.
Puts me in it.
Clicks play.
This causes an invite to get
created which causes, in turn,
a notification to get sent
to my Android device.
So I click the notification.
I get taken to the
invite card.
So I don't know what this game
is, but this guy, he looks
pretty shifty.
But I know him.
He's legit.
He's a cool dude.
So I have the option here to
decline the invite if I don't
want to play it.
Well, again, I like this guy.
I'll give it a shot.
So I click the other option
instead, which is game info.
And clicking this takes
me to the Play store.
In the Play store, I have the
option to learn more about the
game, read the reviews,
and, most
importantly, install the game.
Assuming I install the game, I
can use the notification to
get back to the invite card.
This time, I'll have
the play option.
So I click that.
And I'm taken right into
the game to play the
match with my friend.
And thanks to my friend's
invite, I now have a great
game that I can use to play
with my other friends.
All right.
Briefly because I'm really
low on time here.
If you want more multiplayer,
I skipped
over a lot of details.
Please definitely attend
the session later
today in room five.
And let's quickly look
at the summary.
We introduced the
services today.
I talked about how the
services can increase
discovery through
both badging and
through multiplayer invites.
Lots of libraries and tools.
Certainly, we talked about the
iOS and Android integration
with a bunch of code samples.
And finally, the absolute best
part of the presentation was
this [INAUDIBLE] summary.
If you want to find out more,
this is but one of a plethora
of talks available at
I/O. We have four
more, plus a code lab.
This is all online, so I'm not
going to read over it.
We actually just posted our
developer documentation.
This is live.
Definitely check it out.
If you have questions,
we have answers.
But we're not going
to take them here.
We're actually going to have
Office Hours for 30 minutes
following the talk.
You can come find
all of us there.
Definitely ask lots
of questions.
We're also going to be
around the show for
the rest of the week.
Please talk to us any time.
We're happy to chat with you.
And that is it.
Thank you very much.